So, show you results of some of their
experiments since they have the results
easily available on the Web.
Now, when this paper was written,
which was a while ago,
they were running 30 frames per
second on a 320 by 240 image.
So now it can go faster because time
passes and machines get faster.
They are also only using
500 possible samples.
That's 500 possible new proposals.
Now maybe you can do 5,000.
They use 50 eigenvectors.
Maybe you could use more.
It is the actual numbers
don't matter yet.
The goal it was nice and
it was kind of in real time.
In fact, that's why I put down it runs
at XXX frames per second using Matlab.
Where XXS is, XXX is going to be more
than two and less than 90,000, so
it's in there somewhere.
It depends on how fast your computer is.
So here's some results
that they show you.
Now up here this is the main image, and
you can see they're
tracking the face there.
What you're going to see here
is going to be mostly about
where the image is being explained best.
We're going to talk about that
more when we talk about occlusion.
And what you're going to see
down here are about 10 of the,
of the eigenbases, right?
And you're going to see that they're
changing as the appearance changes.
So if I press, there we go.
All right.
And so
you can see that it's doing a pretty
fine job of explaining the the face.
Sorry, of tracking the face.
That middle row that I was talking
about, that has to do with
what am I seeing versus how well can I
reconstruct it from the basis set, and
it's using that as its evaluation.
And you can see,
with really large lighting variations,
it tracks really well.
You saw it got stuck there at
the very end, and that sort of, as,
as far as it could go.
Yeah, here's another example where
you're going to see a lot of sort of
change in orientation and
change of appearance,
and this is Sylvester
the cat being tracked.
And you can see that it creates a lot
of really sort of creepy lookingSyl-,
Sylvesters on the bottom.
Those are the eigen, the eigan cats.
The images of, of the thing, and, and
that's how it's doing its tracking.